Google shut down its Chinese search
engine in 2010 at the time they said it
was because China was attacking free
speech but things have changed left
doesn't care about free speech anymore
so it was no surprise today to see new
reports that Google is building a
brand-new censored search engine who
allowed to re-enter the Chinese market
will be actively abetting the Communist
police state there and crushing dissent
Google's behavior doesn't end there
though in China last year Google opened
a major artificial intelligence Research
Center in that country even though China
is aggressively pursuing military uses
of artificial intelligence against the
United States
Scott Cleveland is the author of Search
and Destroy you can't trust Google Inc
he joins us tonight
it's got good to see you so if your
corporate motto was don't be evil it
seems like helping a communist police
state crush dissent would fall into the
evil category right absolutely I mean
we're talking about how can you mess
with one point four billion people how
can you aid and abet the oppression of
the largest country in the world so it's
definitely it's it's hard to believe
within a country with the market cap
that Google has the most powerful
company in the history of the world
maybe the richest country in the company
in history the world would be so
desperate for more market share that
they would help prop up a police state
but that seems like what they're doing
well what's really interesting is I was
all about power
it wants to be influential and it wants
to be everywhere for everything and so
that it can't stand the fact that it's
not playing in China and because it sees
1.4 billion people that it doesn't track
and it doesn't know about and so that's
really what they want they really covet
power and information is power to them
that's what's always scared me about
this company is you know I there's it
makes no sense to centralize all the
world's information in one place and
controlled by one person
information is power for them but their
pitch was always
will empower the rest of us as well but
the deal that they are striking in China
would withhold information from the
population they would be complicit in
the brainwashing and propaganda efforts
of the Chinese government it's exactly
the opposite of what they said Google
was about look what they're doing is the
completely opposite of what they
promised everybody or what they've said
they've stood for they've said they stay
or don't be evil they were for freedom
of speech they were for a free and open
Internet they were for net neutrality
which is never supposed to block
anything and they were the main
corporate funder of that and this is
basically blocking every single freedom
website in the world from getting into
China
there's nothing neutral about that
there's nothing free nothing open
nothing good about what they're talking
about doing no it's fascist and where
the hell is the American left on this
why are they continuing to defend this
company which is aiding again in the
oppression of a police state of its own
people
I hopefully they're gonna come around
because this one is completely
indefensible I mean even Google
themselves stood up and said we can't do
this this is too bad yet seven years
they're coming back and doing it in much
larger scale than they were gonna do
before Congress should take action
against Google immediately my opinion
Scott thank you very much it's good
thank you that perspective